yes although Ukraine is not part of NATO
against stoltenberg's visit to Kiev
yesterday was the first time he's
actually visited and he re-emphasized
Ukraine's rightful places within NATO
and he also charged a course for the for
Ukraine to actually uh graduate into
NATO's ownership but it was interesting
today that the Kremlin has also made
clear that one of the reasons they
invaded Ukraine was to stop Ukraine from
joining NATO but today stoltenberger has
increased the rhetoric even further as
you say he's said that all NATO members
now agree that Ukraine will eventually
uh join NATO this was on the eve of the
Ukrainian contact group that's happening
in Ramstein tomorrow this is the U.S led
Coalition of the Willing that the
coordinating military aid for Ukraine
it's not just NATO it's NATO plus really
um and is interesting isn't it how
significant do you think this moment is
the fact that NATO moving towards
accepting Ukraine as a member it's very
significant
um but I think for me the real question
is how whether whether actually Ukraine
is being looked to be fast-tracked if
you recall that Finland was fast-tracked
into NATO uh the fastest nation's ever
been and Sweden likewise they're
expected to Fast Track that through two
um but of course both those Nations
already met NATO requirements but they
wanted to remain neutral as soon as they
decide they didn't want neutrality it
was almost like they were pre-approved
whereas there are very strict entry
requirements for entering NATO we don't
have the time to go through them now but
one of them is the ability to make
meaningful and significant military
contributions to Nato it'll be quite
some time before Ukraine manages to meet
that requirement and also it's worth
pointing out that at the end of the war
between Russia and Ukraine there will
need to be a negotiation uh it's very
difficult to see that Russia would agree
to any negotiated settlement that saw
Ukraine join NATO so the real issue
there is what are the security
arrangements for Ukraine at the end of
the conflict and almost certainly
president zlenski will not spoken word
or written bit of paper given that in
1994 The Budapest member was signed that
guaranteed the sovereignty and the
security of Ukraine which Russia ignored
completely 30 years later that's really
interesting all the different
consequences of this uh to be worked out
and whenever we have you on Sean I
always like to get a bit of a sense
about what the latest situation is on
the ground in Ukraine what can you tell
us
well I think the most fascinating story
today is the Russians admitting that
last night
um and su-34 one of their
state-of-the-art Fighters
um actually bombed one of their own
cities up at Belgrade which is only
about 30 miles away from the Ukrainian
border
um interestingly the the there's a big
crater made in the middle of the city 20
meters wide it upturned a car as well
and apparently we've got reports of at
least two casualties only injured
although if you see by the state of the
devastation it's hard to imagine that
won't increase the su-34 is actually a
state-of-the-art relatively modern
Soviet aircraft uh about 10 of these
have been lost since the start of the
war there's about 19 platforms the real
question is how on Earth did this happen
initial Reports say for the Russians
that they had jettisoned uh the weapons
well as a former fighter pilot myself
you have the ability to jettison stores
fuel tanks and weapons but when they
leave the aircraft they leave in an
unarmed State they cannot possibly
explode whereas these blew up when they
hit their targets almost certainly they
were intended to be released the
challenges did the pilot misidentify a
Target 30 miles away from enemy
territory so it looks unlikely well
looks most likely is that before this
fighter pilot entered into Ukraine
airspace he was probably doing some
training getting used to the switchery
practicing attacks on uh on targets
without actually intending to release a
bomb made his switches live and it
inadvertently released a bomb which
caused such Devastation on the ground
the Russian fighter this is a very
capable fighter but it just illustrates
that equipment alone is not military
capability their pilots are good but
they don't get the flying hours they
don't have the simulator time and this
is a very embarrassing incident but it
also highlights the relative
incompetence of some of the Russian Air
Force pilots